We have 3x of degree α by bx ^ 4,
which equals -24x6.
Pause the video and see if you can find a and b.
To find them, we can multiply this left side,
so let's do it.
What we have here,
we can just write it as 3 x x degree,
on b by x on fourth.
And we can change the order.
We simply multiply 4 different things.
It's the same as 3 in b,
by x of degree a,
x per fourth.
If you decide it yourself,
there is no need to do all these steps,
but I want to make clear what is actually happening.
And how much will it be?
Well we have ...
Let me write it in a new color.
here we have 3b.
This is 3b,
but how many x is in degree x x in fourth?
x of degree a by x of fourth.
We have the same foundation, elevated to varying degrees
and we multiply them.
We know from the properties of the pointers,
that it is the same as x of degree a plus four.
x is equal to x (a + 4).
We just collect the grade pointers,
because we have the same foundation and multiply the two numbers.
So now we have
3b by x of degree a plus four.
And this will be equal to what,
which we have on the right side.
This will be equal to ...
I will write it in the same color.
This is equal to -24x6.
What can we do now?
We can notice that
3b must be equal to -24
a + 4 here must be equal to 6.
Let's save it.
3b equals -24.
Surely you can solve it in your mind
or if you want to solve it a little more systematically,
you can divide both sides to 3,
to find b.
And you get b equal to -8.
We can also say that a + 4 equals 6.
You get 4 on both sides and you get,
that a is equal to 2.
And we're ready.
If you want, you can check it out.
We can write it like ...
If we say that a is equal to 2,
we can say 3x ^ 2 on ...
Here, instead of b, it is -8,
-8x4.
What will that be equal to?
3 at 8 is -24.
x ^ 2 by x ^ 4 is x ^ 6.
And once again - it is not necessary
to do all these steps,
if you decide on a piece of paper.
But when you see the initial task,
you have to say, "I can multiply the coefficients 3 by b,
to get this coefficient here. "
So 3 in b is -24,
b should be -8.
So b here should be -8.
And you could say that x in degree a x in fourth
is x on the sixth.
So, let's see, step indicators,
a + 4 will be equal to 6,
therefore a = 2.
So you can do it so easily,
but that's how you do it,
even if you do it in mind.